enfin encore la fête de saverney à
Ornans qui se faisait le 22 janvier jour
de Saint-Vincent et qui donnait lieu à
des festivités mais réservé aux seuls
vignerons
alors nous avons pensé qu'il fallait
absolument
que cette fête devienne une fête de
toute la vallée et qu'elle devienne nous
inspirons des burkilles des Bourguignons
puisqu'ils ont la Saint-Vincent tournant
sur les les coteaux de
Nuits-Saint-Georges
au-delà nous avons pensé que nous
pourrions les imiter c'est comme ça
qu'un petit comité très réduit au départ
c'est constitué et Monsieur curé était
avec nous d'ailleurs Michel curé de vie
à fond aussi et nous avons décidé de
relancer la fête de sa dernière en
lavant tournante et c'est comme ça que
tous les six ans maintenant elle revient
dans chaque ville voilà
[Musique]
l'essentiel c'est qu'il y a eu un homme
qui s'appelle Vernier Werner en
qui a été martyr qui était vignerons
Arthur bon j'ai pas trop dans quelle
circonstances en tout cas il a été
toujours vénéré dans la région comme
patron des vignerons et alors
nous avons enfin par que depuis combien
de fois
[Musique]
j'avais combien 3 siècles ou quatre
quatre
vénéré dans la vallée
comment cette dévotion est-elle venue il
y a parfois une confusion avec
Saint-Vincent
qu'importe l'essentiel c'est que les
vignerons se reconnaissent sur le
patronage dans un patron
[Musique]
le Seigneur
bénir ce pain et se vint et donne-nous
la nourriture dont nous avons besoin
pour notre corps et notre esprit par
Jésus le Christ de notre Seigneur
on recherche aussi dans la vallée tous
les champs pour fans ce qui permet
d'avoir un répertoire très étendu et en
même temps de pouvoir chanter et des
champs profanes au repas de la savernier
mais c'est très difficile de les avoir
mais souvent les gens on les paroles
mais pas souvent la musique
tout n'est pas traditionnel il y a des
chants qui ont été composés et écrits
très connus et puis il a fait les
paroles ce qui permet bien sûr c'est des
paroles quand même qui ont rapport à la
vallée
et il y a pas rien que lui il y a aussi
le père Bègue qui en a fait enfin on a
plusieurs paroliers mais enfin c'est
très bien Gustave Courbet qui a fait le
chant final le chant des vignerons c'est
les paroles sont de Gustave Courbet
alors c'est pareil on a retrouvé aussi
dans les archives de la famille enfin
c'est très bien de conserver comme ça
dans la famille oui il avait été recopié
par mon grand-père mais il avait bien
marqué que les paroles étaient de
Gustave
alors il l'avait fait un petit peu
ironique sur les sur les vignerons mais
enfin il est quand même très bien et de
premier couplets on peut les chanter
permettrait pas d'avoir le troisième à
l'écrire
savez-vous bien ce qu'il a lui procure
[Musique]